hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fail man speaking of fail
somewhere on the way to Vegas I lost my
glasses actually before I even got to
Vegas I couldn't find my glasses and I
thought could find him when I got back
but unfortunately I have to make do with
context for right now so if this seems
weird to you it is infinitely weirder to
me because for the past three years I've
barely recorded one video without my
glasses on so now would be the time to
panic and scream in the comments below
please rampage Rage Against the Machine
push and shove okay let's play fail man
this is actually made by the same guy
that made troll face quest so expect
some similarities between the two of
them and actually looking at this it
seems extremely similar hi okay cool how
does that help me at all you just broken
alrighty then
thank you okay
alright cool that went as I thank you
it's like troll face except he's not
trolling me because he wants to he's
trolling me because he's stupid I don't
like the story in my life hello little
girl
how are you doing what he was wrong how
can I make your oh you want a balloon
where do I get a balloon oh hi
okay hi this can't go good can it oh no
oh no oh no I somehow knew that was
gonna happen that poor little girl
that's like death why would that be okay
well actually I guess none of this is
okay hello are you gonna get splashed oh
no what have I done I'll save you I'm
fail man
thank you is there any way to lose this
it seems to be pretty simple here I'll
play subs ro and Luke on any day I want
to do wrong
uh-huh okay either the barrels of fuel
or you're gonna get yes yes you've
almost well hey wait you know yes maybe
I don't know this isn't fail man you're
just an idiot Oh actually I think he's
malicious I'm pretty sure he's intending
to do all this crap
he really is hello that seems like a
change of scenery how's it going over
here
hey Zombo thank you
that guy was really bugging me huh yeah
oh wow alright then
he's system malicious mass murderer he's
out to kill everybody how's this in any
way good okay
hi how's it going film in No please stay
away from him he doesn't want your help
it just was a little water oh hi what
how
okay that's kind of a fate worse than
death
hello oh no you're out of power well I'm
sure I'll find some way to electrocute
you just you wait fail man is on the way
where is he
hello hi how's it going any day now he's
gonna come murder you oh oh thank you
hint wow he's a spider on the okay well
this I yeah he's dead okay he's dead
good job fail man the world's worst
villain never noon and then you took his
cell phone okay
this is teaching everybody happy fun
lessons oh it's the same Bank okay you
could help this guy oh I was gonna get
to that hi hello I just got done helping
a guy escape his family by going to jail
you wants ml buddy oh all right then
sure why not oh no no no no no stop
please dear God it's not okay all right
that's moderately a little bit better
well the old lady's dead now no I was
expecting this hello
I need the blushing bride to be prepared
out of your whole entire life ruined
okay anyway hello excuse you why did you
have an F on your shirt
yep that seems about right right in her
face hope that wasn't nearly as deadly
as I thought it was gonna be so okay
hello hi little girl
how you doing I don't know what these
are sure I'll suck this lake why not
okay there's a luster of many evils that
you've done I guess I'm okay with this
what do we do stop stop a oncoming
traffic yeah take that you're probably
not okay but at least the Ducks are okay
because as far as I know those are
Google automated cars I think I want to
think you don't think I don't think much
of anything else game okay what are you
doing at Internet chat room hunter Inc
ABCD F how about yes how are you gonna
help them to a bad website okay don't do
don't step away you creepy bastard no
step away step away step back okay so
gentle and nice oh look at that he's
such a voyeur
okay alright one of his hard eyes is
throbbing
hello well you gave your bride a black
guy I don't know what else you should be
waiting for how about the F hello
fail man just in time to ruin this poor
guy's day wouldn't you know it he needs
so much help
okay
hi what okay she gets angry and then
immediately returns to being okay okay
hello oh no it's that guy who lost his
family and gone to jail I supposed to do
something okay fine
bail man help help damn it ah yes okay
that makes sense now no one can get
anywhere
all right great Oh No
Justin Beaver is that what this is this
Justin Beaver we're beating up Justin
Bieber right now oh well he's dead now
you kicked his anus into his brain dude
you don't know the trouble you're about
to be in stop putting your thumb out
don't even try okay oh why did you steal
all of his stuff because it works
okay well I guess All Things Considered
that was actually good he was stuck in
the middle of a desert he probably was
gonna die of thirst oh no no no stop no
stop stop stop
don't do it oh hey how's it going okay
jump in there do that thing oh that's
awesome
I guess cool I did it whoa I destroyed
everything civilization has ended
because of my negligence oh boy alright
so that was fail man I guess everything
is gonna be a-okay are there any other
secret levels knows it okay so if you
want to see the other games that I
played by this guy trollface quest is
pretty much exactly the same except in a
different rapper but they're all fun
they're all funny and this guy makes
great games he does great stuff so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the annotation for videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
it's good for it may not be good for you
you'd probably enjoy this